is the next evolution of gaming hitting
a team of four playable hunters against
one powerful player controlled monster
or 4v1
experienced the intensity of the hunt
online or hone their skills offline solo
however you play no two matches will be
the same the playing field is as level
as it is treacherous adrenaline is
guaranteed but if you want to survive
you better listen up to what's in store
team up and work together as the hunters
or evolve and kill alone is the monster
it's survival of the fittest and any
side can win choose your side I just got
off the line with colony command this is
no longer a wildlife problem it's a
full-scale evacuation gear up welcome to
sheer don't be fooled by the planet's
natural beauty every living thing out
here big or small as
to chew you up and spit you out or worse
to hunt here we've got to be tough
or crazy that's where they come in
dropping on to shear is the galaxy's
most lethal and eccentric band of
creature killers the hunters our team
afford unique classes assault trapper
medic and support must work together to
track trap and kill the monster before
he evolves to the ultimate stage three
and kills them all there are three
characters in every class each with a
special loadout for a total of 12
hunters every class has a unique
responsibility to fill or the team works
together they become an unstoppable
killing machine armed with an itchy
trigger finger and a penchant for
destruction the assault class is the
damage dealer bringing along a vast
arsenal of lethal weapons and explosives
to the hunt the medic class is no
stranger to the frontlines they keep the
team in fighting shape with first aid
and emergency revives you can't run and
you can't hide when a trapper is bearing
down on you tracking devices lead the
hunters to their prey and the mobile
arena ensures it stays there and when
you need a boost the support class is
there he can buff the team to make them
stronger or use heavy weapons to pack a
hell of a punch when each hunter plays
to their roles works as a team
kids effectively they can emerge from a
battle victorious these creatures
overwhelmed colonial security forces in
less than a week clearly we're dealing
with something far beyond ordinary
wildlife merely the hunters might have
strength in numbers but the monster is a
powerful and punishment adversary all on
its own
there are three known types of monsters
Goliath meets a trail of fire and rubble
wherever he kills he's a savage beast of
pure strength and brutality Kraken is a
long-range predator ascending from above
this beast kills with dark energy and
his vicious tentacles for the shadows
the raid strikes she is a fast moving
assassin who uses stealth in this
direction kickoff hunters monsters
evolved by feasting on sheers indigenous
wildlife the more the creature eats the
faster it progresses to the next stage
each stage allows the monster to level
up gaining more power and abilities as
well as increase in their armor and
health play to your strengths and you
will become the ultimate one-man army
when you have the hunters in your sight
remember what it feels like to face down
the baddest boss ever because guess what
you are one they are afraid very afraid
evacuation drops you headfirst into the
ferocious battle for sheer in a totally
unique and highly replayable campaign
that can be played online or solo
offline and spanning five days the
campaign contains all maps and modes
found in the game each day is a battle
featuring a different mode on a
different map the outcome of those
battles directly affects the events of
the next day if the hunters kill the
monster they might receive armored
turrets or additional allies if the
monster destroys an objective the
hunters might face man-eating eels in
their next mission there are over
800,000 possible combinations expect the
unexpected
I value spraying fire though in phases
this ain't a vacation this [ __ ]
paradise
in hunt mode the monster must evade and
outsmart the hunters long enough to
evolve to stage three and destroy the
map objective the hunters must work
together to track and finally kill the
monster and the beast downs all of them
first it's game over
and nest the hunters must work fast to
destroy the monsters eggs before time
runs out
meanwhile the monster must hatch an egg
to spawn a minion together they need to
defend the monsters brood at all cost
rescue finds the lives of sheer
civilians hanging in the balance
the monster must kill the colonists
before the hunters can escort them to
the evacuation point in defend mode a
series of generators are the only thing
protecting an evacuation ship from total
destruction it'll be a desperate fight
to the end as the hunters defend a
generator against the stage 3 alpha
monster and its minions all of evolves
modes can be experienced online or
offline solo the battle for Scheer is
full of possibilities will you save the
colony or be the monster that destroys
it